lsd is like mushrooms
on acid and it is it is acid so it's
it's a funny amount
hello hello
america how are you no
said don't you know me i'm
native son said um the train
they call the spirit of new orleans
there's a lot
in that song right what i just say yeah
it's a lot you go like wait you're a
train
three lines in you're like you're a
[ __ ]
you called yourself okay trains can't
talk it's all
guys gay guys uh
spirit padre has a small message
what the spirit padre
learned is you uh
first of all everyone keeps dming me for
numbers and information never ever ever
i'm not gonna give out a number as we
talked about
go on reddit and you can go on trip
advice literally tripadvisor has
ayahuasca
uh yeah just google it retreat you
google it you could you bang it
you even got to google it you have to
get up you can ask
jeeves duck duck go it use just use your
entire
portfolio of search engines uh
because we're we're we it's i'm not
gonna go like all right call this guy
anybody i don't know yeah
right like so
uh what i will say though is just make
sure
the place you go is
legit iowa is certified and
there's a like a very very
experienced shaman slash shop
shop women shop shop shop people
uh so just because i i feel
the the the more i don't the more
responsible i feel
for yeah now you're and you've got it
well when you call yourself spiritually
heavy heavy heavy as well
the head who's who is the padre
that's that's my that's my my cross
what is the padre it's a shawl really
i'm wearing a shawl
the padre's wearing a shawl what do you
mean papa padre the spirit padre
wearing a multi-colored shawl
um with a swoosh yeah and well yeah i'm
sponsored uh
so just it's got to be don't don't do
any back
again it's not like back alley it's all
and you might need to just wait until
after covid
because the really good places are
in peru and
ecuador and um costa rica and brazil
so i think that's like i feel like
that's where
i need to be yeah because uh well
yeah so your takeaway is after doing it
this first time just
just make sure the person knows what i
don't i just i feel like uh
i just don't want someone to do it
because i said and then and then be like
dude
you said you you said everyone was good
at it no well also
everyone's not they're not all created
equal in the end we both
gleaned benefits from ayahuasca and i
had my
experience and you've had really good
experiences yeah and so
they can there's no one guarantee
yeah you're it may vary yeah yeah
moderate or moderate to severe plaque
right black arthritis
plaque psoriasis uh yeah your void were
prohibited
all that [ __ ] uh caveat
buyer beware for household uh etc etc
um not transferable uh
me and b this is called neil and bianca
say things they've seen
on in public places yes
so that was uh that's my that's my
spirit padre
caveat it's gotta run 20 20.
it's gotta um now bianca
uh what an earth what a world we live in
things are happening continuously moving
on
you're not going to believe this what
tell me rudy giuliani
what did he do he got coveted
i mean i feel like
he's been so embarrassing like it lately
more than yes ever uh
they always use that photo that said the
photo now
when he was the uh frack face
he fracked his own face um
that like the covet is i almost thought
didn't i thought he already had it
like in my head i was like oh didn't
they all get it well the joke that
everybody's making it i mean the
easy joke is like coveted contracts rudy
giuliani
oh yeah uh chris's joke pray for kovit
it uh apparently covet can travel from
bat to human
and back to bat uh some of these are
recycled somewhere
stephen miller got it oh yeah yeah it's
always a template yeah there's a
template for everybody hey look you're
in comedy logo you're gonna see some
some uh some some repeat templates
um so i don't
know america is getting to the point
now and this speaks to
melissa caroni the woman
the star witness star witness our expert
uh yes i.t witness uh she i
that's ironically enough that is that's
his
um what was the movie that he loved
my cousin vinnie oh yeah she's the
marisa tomei of his my cousin vinnie and
it doesn't but she's
bad and she didn't help and
she's a bat i don't know if she said you
know what she was on
she was a i t tech she she was i
t tech for dominion or whatever the [ __ ]
okay um the thing she was saying were
it was hard to follow even like saturday
night live
parodied it but when you're watching it
it was like
it was she's a crazy person it was like
you know
she's just a crazy person like harasses
her ex-fiance
by sending her sex tapes her ex-fiance
oh yeah she would send her ex-fiance
she would send her fiance's ex sex tapes
of her and her
oh her fiance's ex-wife yes that's
so now having said that if a melissa
corone
sends you a sex tape that's
automatically terrifying it doesn't
matter if you know when it is
if she's in the tape not good it is
a hate crime it's at least a hate crime
so but here's what i here's how i feel
with what giuliani's doing with what
tell me about melissa
caroni i don't know how to say it this
is caronie tomate
we gotta keep it uh
melissa corona i mean if you really want
to be topical about it
um uh is i'm
you know when we've talked about leslie
when
they released pictures of leslie jones
how i would not look
that's how i feel about a lot of this
stuff
with anything giuliani does
melissa corona uh [ __ ] all the joy
any anything trump uh
just all of it is so
embarrassing for the country that i
don't want to see it hoping
that in some ways it will not
belittle my impression of the country
like i don't if i see this
i i may not come back from this you're
you're really sensitive to things like
this though like the aoc makeup
them no they're different families aoc
makeup is just irresponsible
no but i doesn't it come from a place of
just you're in an important position
just do
the important position thing don't you i
was saying
i was saying somewhere where you don't
wear shorts
around people that work for you
i don't want to see my therapist at the
beach i don't want to see
but i don't but i had a i did a me and
lauren michael's talking one time where
i was like you'd never wear shorts
around people you work with
under no circumstances you're done
once someone sees you in shorts or like
i remember i did a pilot 20 years ago
and one of the execs came in running
shorts
and it was like oh this is over this is
the whole thing is over
um like thigh like daisy dude like
white guy daisy duke running shorts it
was it was over
of course the pile didn't get picked up
um so
i don't so with any one of these things
even if i have a friend that's doing a
sitcom
that i know is bad i just will never
look at it
so that i don't it i
it will go into my cumulative score oh
of course and i don't want it to
so i will i said a friend of mine had a
sick on one time and i said
i watching it felt like watching in isis
that's what you said that to the friend
no i know or her
um uh guess who it was
you will you may not guess um but that's
how i feel about america
with this is like an isis tape america's
being in some ways beheaded
some way in some ways people go well
yeah because the left is cheating and
no it's not this is not good it's not
good it's not a good
some of these fights are not
i'm not saying we can't come back from
them but they're just
not constructive at all we've entered
the part of the breakup where
he or she won't leave yeah and so okay
i'll move out
but it's your house so you're like
and that's the other i was gonna do yeah
i was gonna do it on the daily show like
hey we're roommates yeah we
can't like it was
i had the original idea with um the
russia hacking the thing it's like yeah
russia hacked uh
hacked it this time and you guys won but
next time it you could lose and
i as a liberal i'd rather have a set of
rules that we
absolutely have to abide by right
because we're roommates
and this is we're literally chained
together
so if you get sick i get sick
or in this case i i whatever they
didn't get whatever they got an immunity
idol as it were
if i continued survivor
um metaphors uh so
this giuliani
you know i told i've been doing a joke
that you're you would never believe this
but in 2002
after 9 11 the two biggest heroes in new
york were cops and rudy giuliani
it seems like science fiction literally
could not
convince someone that there was a time
where afrofuturistic storytelling
oh by the way we have drops now from the
bianca was lucky enough to obtain the
entire art of speculating
it's so boring the art of speculating
so dude we've had will chop it up um
they will be uh hopefully a part of our
uh
part of our show now until for example
when he
says atlanta i mean will
atlan's atlanta
this is all neil's old man phrases come
on i
knew a woman who lived in a shoe
who when i was working for all that how
old are you neil
i know a woman who did background on the
elevators video
how old are you the elevators
the elevators the atf that's how it goes
elevate okay sorry sorry
i'm sorry um um i know a woman wait
background that's who did background
it's not even like that's a bad job i'm
just saying no i'm like it's so long ago
yeah um
and um yeah so that's how old i am yeah
you know people who worked on
classics yeah i know people who like
like iconic
things i know one of the uh co-creators
that's how old i am um
so just to put that in person okay
i love saying it when people go i was i
was born in 1999 i'm like i had
problems in nightmares like [ __ ]
parabolas
doctors and pills and a heavy heavy-duty
situation
uh so if you can
avert avert your gaze from
some of these things the same way that
you and i
post spirit padre activity have
don't have much taste for true crime
or murder do you still are you turned
off both were you ever yeah i
i tried to i there was a bunch of [ __ ]
that i could not
it's weird it weirds me out on my reddit
i have a
i follow a lot of um unresolved
mysteries subreddit
these true crime and when i'm i
jump i don't even read it it's like
toddler
was found in the park alive
hello er playing skippers bye goodbye uh
i don't wanna know at all and it
i do a little spooky here and there i
can do a little x-files
just so i'm feeling crazy uh but no i
i i can't there's something about my
brain that
it like healed i don't know it like
sealed off
yeah the receptors yeah which is kind of
a bummer
well i like freed up time it frees time
up basically
it it it you have there's an hour now
a day or whatever you're not where you
just can do something else
yeah sit ups i do i bought a bike did
you
hmm don't mind if i do well like a
peloton or
outside bike oh no an outside bike
i don't make that much money
um guys that's what you did you did that
you bought bianca by
bicycle bicycle i don't know i can't
call it a bike
uh somehow bicycle is better she thinks
it's not it's french
is not a bicycle it's a stationary bike
i know that's why i said bicycle because
i didn't have a pelton
i i don't i don't know what's going on i
said bicycle and you said bike
okay or something something happened um
what were you gonna say i was gonna just
lump it all in with the
the georgia debates since it's all i
didn't watch
uh follows me on instagram
really yeah and i didn't know that and
i've said a lot of no i didn't i dm'd
him and i was like if you need
like i said i had already sent him money
oh yeah uh
but i don't think it's just to follow
for any reason it's he follows like 700
people and
your friend is one of them oh wow so not
at any reason
um so i said do you want i already sent
him money but i was like if you need
punch up or yeah let me know
what do you say he hasn't gotten back to
me uh so
the white lady says she's the least she
doesn't have a racist bone in her body
elise raises prisons in the room it was
it was like a standard kind of thing
it wasn't like some i mean she did she
already looks like
this is snl she looks like the white
ring
kelly lovely wait the right ring the
white ring the ring the girl from the
ring
but the white then we'll call it the
engagement ring
that's the white version of the ring the
wire she looks like she climbed out of a
well
and is here she climbed out of a well at
one of those
outdoor malls like the grove or
something
and she climbed out of a well there it
was like she climbed out of a fountain
let's be honest
oh yeah she didn't she wasn't in a well
one of those like town
regular [ __ ] town square usa type
malls
uh i like the girl where they have their
own trolley
just [ __ ] stop it
yeah it it made me think that without
i do wonder about the republican party
when trump's gone because i think
trump unified everybody together
but without trump it's an extremely
fracture party i mean both parties are
fractured but uh i don't
i wonder without that unifying force
that everybody got behind i
i do wonder about american politics one
biden is the president and nobody can do
anything and
let's say well biden's gonna be able to
do a lot of [ __ ] if
everyone in georgia who's who's liberal
endless has registered for the
for the for the runoff and
look man that's the thing i was thinking
before our podcast sometimes i'll think
wow and there's a lot of people
that are right wing in america there's
just a lot of there's just a lot of
people that are republican
yeah and the only way for
liberals to beat them is every you just
it's
it's so obvious but every single liberal
has to vote in
every single election they can yeah it's
that's the only way to get
any sort of lib
i mean a liberal agenda sounds scary but
just a
a a democratic agenda like
capital d 1970s 80s democrat like biden
is
hard i was doing the arms
uh yeah i was doing the old heave hope
and uh
every single [ __ ] election it it has
to be urgent
because if it's like i don't feel like
this one or uh
you can't not feel like it yeah because
the republicans show up
yes but it's also such a thin margin in
terms of
the amount of liberals versus the amount
or the amount of democrats versus the
amount of republicans we're really split
it's like we're
for so we have so many people in this
country even though
there are more liberals i think
i don't statistically it's not it that i
don't think it's borne out i think
statistically well
you wouldn't mind typing it uh oh yeah
the amount of
liberals versus uh republicans americans
oh yeah u.s still leans conservative
that was a year no but that but liberals
keep
this january 2020
uh center right yeah it's center right
so it is right it's not that but i
wonder how many
techn like how many more people because
it is center right on
the issues but a lot of people are maybe
identify as liberals but don't vote
aren't they cute
again if you're center right if everyone
voted then the country would be
center-right
so a lot of people voted and the country
is was almost center i mean super
whatever i don't know what trump is yeah
uh but what i'm saying is
they the uh the amount of liberals
versus the amount of
by the latest by gallup in i think this
is
earlier 2020 right which again much has
changed
and it's 35 37 conservative
24 liberal and 35
moderate so yeah it's that's this is
what i was talking about
a month ago where it's like be
[ __ ] persuasive and stop acting like
people are liberal they're not [ __ ]
liberal
stop it but then trump could not
you know you're always saying to
liberals hey pandered to like don't
pander to the base pan her to the middle
right but i know yeah what i'm saying is
that
trump didn't pander to the middle at all
because there's 37 percent
republican he doesn't need to he doesn't
he needs
much less of the middle than democrats
do just statistically
he needs by my calculation 13
13. 13 fewer people in the middle
than than democrats so right there
it proved my my my my point but what i'm
saying is
uh we just have to [ __ ]
vote in every election and we have to uh
liberals do and we have to be persuasive
you can't be
hectoring you can't be yelling to people
you can't be talking down to people you
just
it's not gonna work if you want
it's like uh it's it's
it's uh it's like america's foreign
policy where it's it's
freedom by by point of bayonet it's like
there's
uh maybe try it different a different
way you're not persuasion by by yelling
is has a zero percent effectiveness
right so you don't think
by because you're really critical of i
was critical of
dividing but he did it i wasn't critical
no i wouldn't correct it
you said you said i said shut the [ __ ]
up about
race and gender that's yeah and by the
way
he did they eventually yeah yeah
eventually but they
but the closer the election got the less
they brought up
a woman and a brown and a they just
uh right but she is a brown woman it's
not hard to see and she did
then i didn't say don't nominate her i
said
shut the [ __ ] up about it i'm not saying
you said that but i'm saying that he did
he was more he was the less liberal of
all the people in the prime minister yes
he was the most centrist and then just
people on the left
assailed him i wasn't saying i was
saying
get away from the far left and play it
down
that's where the [ __ ] people are is
in the middle i don't it's do i want a
middle agenda
no but i'd rather have a compromise
liberal agenda than than a republican
agenda
whereas most liberals either want a
liberal agenda or
nothing but that's most people that's
not just now it's especially liberal
you think that's not the verb you know
the phrase because i've said it on here
before
say it liberals fall in love republicans
fall online republicans go
this is the guy great where do i vote
they don't go well i think he could be
mark i might sit this one out because
they don't play that [ __ ] it's a it's a
babyish liberal
disposition and it exists only for
liberals because republicans come i
don't give a [ __ ] as long as we get
republican uh judicial yeah
it's in lower texas i don't care i
really don't care about the rest of them
they only talk like clinch yes because
there's a lot of blacks
around um so
you know yeah it's just i i
i wonder but the because you live in la
and are from the bay you assume the
country is mostly liberal
uh no i [ __ ] don't know i didn't say
it based on that
first of all because that's super
narrow-minded and ignorant i understand
the middle of america is not
a same reflection of the most
progressive place
in america is where i'm born from you
know what i mean i don't think it's the
same thing
i said that because more people seven
more million
seven million more people voted for
biden than trump i just was and i was
under the impression that like
besides voting just people the the
population really is in a few
major cities like half or more of the
population is in a few
giant cosmopolitan cities that are
mostly left-leaning so i didn't say
that all the countries like california i
mean no no but i don't
i'm not i'm assuming the reason you said
there are more liberals than republicans
which is because of the vote because
that's the presidential vote
in the in the like we liberals lost
democrats lost seats
no i understand that i didn't say how
many
registered voters are republican i just
was
wondering if the country as a whole as
everybody in the country
most of them if the majority is left
leaning or right laning and that's
that was what i was wondering we can't
really find that convention
my point is when you grow up you
if you it's impossible to fathom uh
that most people are that 37 to 24
people are are republican over democrats
it's like what
i don't think it's impossible if you've
left your state
of course i've left i leave my state all
the time i know but i'm saying
it's not hard for me to fathom no i
don't know but if i told you that step
beforehand
before we looked at it i'm not i didn't
have a no
most people i just i don't again i
you're seeing this as an attack what i'm
saying is
it's hard for people to
fathom a thing that they don't see
it's like why i was so willing to bet
dave that hillary was going to be trump
right but the day of because he's he was
like dude i'm seeing a lot of [ __ ]
trump signs in ohio and i was like ah
hogwash hooey but it's hot it's re it's
recency bites it's
locally by it's just we're biased people
i know but i
also have been uh into politics for a
really long time so it
is not it is not a surprise to me that
most people are that i'm just wondering
because
most liberals tend to be
younger and most conservatives tend to
be older so i was just wondering like a
number we can't really get to the bottom
of because
you know whatever and then some people
switch and then some people
were live or when they were younger and
they had all these like radical ideas
and then they get money
and they have family or whatever and
then they become a little more
conservative i was just wondering
if the presidential election is a
reflection of the people
or if it was a reflection of how many
people don't like it
a lot of it was the middle
is what's the difference that was the
difference to me it's like persuading
the middle
liberals first democrats were persuading
the middle and
that they were more i would argue that
biden was more persuasive than liz
warren or bernie would have been hm
there are people that are like you know
i know bernie that's the funny thing is
like oof bernie would not have no but
you can't tell bernie
bro who says that roses
all inclusive bernie says did admit that
once she started volunteering for biden
how remote it was
that bernie would have won which was
very satisfying when
when my when neil's point of view is
brought up
and sanctified and glorified
uh there's nothing sweeter than having
your own positions glorified
okay uh remember ellen page
juno forget her
by the name of elliott page elon pay oh
is it ellie
we want to exchange elon as a as a
tribute to
uh to our our our
electric future and like i just love the
brand
and i love what he does and i have the
fire thing i have the flame flower
um have you seen the people testing out
his flamethrower to actual flamethrowers
it's so good this is it's like
the it's like those little green squirt
guns versus a super soaker
his is a super sucker his is the little
green gun yeah well i think
legally i don't i think he was better
off making it a little because i know
one person explodes and it's like
goodbye everything but when you see a
flamethrower work
what the hell who would need that i
was trying to figure out who would need
that i mean they used them
i the only time i've seen i believe
that they've used them
they use them like for real
in uh combat no in in in uh
call of duty in call of duty like the
world war ii ones
and i believe that i actually saw it in
that movie now there it is so that's his
that's the elon musk one that's like a
lighter
yeah that's a cigarette lighter um
yeah that's better again and then this
is like an actual flamethrower
why it seems like that's what they
should use for
i don't know people with knives i don't
know like literally when
could you when is that better if you're
someone's
knifing well just right but why not a
gun
i don't i don't understand why you would
this must have been pre
automatic what i don't know we'll never
automatically oh what do you mean when
they invented it
yeah it does sound like some archaic
[ __ ]
it's super it's like medieval yeah it's
like get the
get the uh battering ram and the and the
like spiked the polly thing that the oh
what is it
elon musk has released someone called
cantabolt uh the english word
flamethrower
from 1901. so it's really makes sense
yeah but that's pretty like very good
guns
yeah that's true and pre-flight
so pretty cool pretty cool uh
that's gonna go in the neil basket with
them pretty good with fireworks
but hey did you know that no flambower
your
flamethrower can get it that can't
fireworks are stupid but flame flowers i
hate that you ate fireworks
uh cool for 18 50.
you know what i wrote down um just now
because we forgot is david sedaris got
in trouble yesterday
well i love davidson i know it's stupid
who doesn't like david david amy the
whole family
bianca david sedaris did a
cbs this morning uh oh my god uh
[ __ ] remote where he it's like an
op-ed where he said
that you should be able to like
citizen's arrest
you should be able to uh be able to just
fire people
at which is [ __ ] hilarious that's so
funny
very funny very funny uh you just could
fire them
like they're doing such a [ __ ] job it's
like yes
take this lifeguard ymca
wmca i brought a guest pass that i could
swim laps 10 minutes after i started the
young mom and blew her whistle and said
you all have to leave now how come i
have to go to my parents house
what right that's what i have so anyhow
people said it was classist
and just a bunch of like howard he's at
the wwmc
how did you get there so that woman you
don't you think what she did was cool
and that we should protect workers
rights in that situation
it's the i have a similar tell me
i love a good pov come on what happened
it might be
it might be more classist it's okay i
assume that
but i'm pretty classist you look close
uh and of course sizes
everybody know it um i
when people say that
lazy people are on welfare
that there are people that are just lazy
and would rather be on unemployment than
get a job
uh i see that as you know when an nba
team when there's a troubled player
will buy them out to get the [ __ ] away
from the team
that's how i see people that are too
lazy because it's like
would i rather that person i'll explain
would i rather that person
be uh at home
living on the dole on the off of welfare
or would i rather that person be at cvs
going like huh can i help you
i don't know like i'd rather just go
home
just get out of here i'd rather you get
unemployment
then then be at work and be [ __ ]
horrible at it and i'm relying on you
for a service
and i mean cvs used to be horrible until
jose wrote a sketch about it and then
they
literally like overhauled their entire
yeah they did a sketch on snl pride two
years ago about like
the premise was that's when they bought
the greeters in
yeah the premise was like who works here
and i don't even remember the sketch
that but the premise was like they're
bad
it was like our kinko sketch on
chappelle's show yeah
it goes you're like an overhaul though
no but that was the most
real [ __ ] yes and every time i go to
kinko's i think of that sketch
uh thank you like uh that was based on
real it's um they fulfill this it's they
fulfill the stereotype
so badly it was i just was listening to
a guy at kinko's one time in new york
and like
uh and he just it was unbelievable
like it was just like horribly
stereotypical
and it he's got a guy that's like just
buy him out i'd rather pay a portion of
my taxes just people that are too dumb
to work
or people that are too
feckless or people that are just don't
want to be there or people that are just
getting
in the way yeah just buy them out the
way that washington
uh wizards bought out gilbert arenas
for bringing a gun to to class he's
weird online no he's a weird dude he's
just a weird dude
and they were right to buy him out
goodbye goodbye
nev doesn't work for anyone else in the
nba no
he got her going picked up by one team
and it i mean what happens a lot of
times is guy's egos get too big
yeah where they get like i think carmelo
got bought up by houston
and then they're just like like you're
not worth the trouble so
that's what i'm saying about cbs kinko's
whomever a lot of people are not worth
the trouble
right like they just don't want to be
there and they don't want to help and
they get in the way
so i don't know if that's better or
worse if i'm canceled if i'm
did i get a raise what's the opposite of
getting canceled am i being exalted
uh yeah i know i get it
so so again david if that's if that's
where we are is that david sedaris can't
say we should be able to make citizens
firings
the same way we make students arrests uh
then uh i'm gonna look away
because i don't wanna see america like
this the thing is you're people who know
you
and follow you and fans of yours uh
i know you like that um he they know you
so i don't think anyone's gonna bad an
eyelash at your opinion but i think
david's fans are uber liberals he has
some
uber i don't i don't he has a very npr's
crowd
by the way so in his tone it is known as
tone but it's the
firing it's somebody else basically he
wrote a thing
in one of his first books like holidays
on ice i believe
where a woman said i'm gonna get you
fired and he was like what do you do
he like was then against her for saying
that
like how are you so so he's like he's
being a hypocrite but
like he got rich and forgotten he's like
no
[Music]
to me i think he would have been in the
same boat
back then but yeah
just he didn't write it he didn't write
it down
and and i also think he would argue that
he was doing a good job
this woman was just being an [ __ ]
right because she could
whereas that person was being but then
it's all like well everything is from
mr sedaris's vantage point yeah well
you're doing a bad job but these these
are such blatant
it's [ __ ] who cares it's just it's
people getting
dumb nonsense and like wait a minute i
think we can get i think i can build a
case here
i know and then a mania an online maniac
i mean he specializes in
satire and we're gonna get upset
well so does everybody that gets in
trouble what so there's kevin hart but
they got upset
because he said he was homophobic 10
years ago and i learned a ton
from kevin getting fired from the oscars
what'd you learn i learned don't be
homophobic
12 years ago that's the number one
lesson i think we can all take
don't write it down don't be homophobic
12 years ago i mean that's it yeah
that's the only thing any of us can take
um is if when you when you're traveled
through time
which as i debunked last week's never
going to happen southern black people
who travel across time and space
um that kid is so great and the funny
thing is he actually sounds like mike d
from the bc boys
he does just naturally
his black voice is mike d's normal voice
and i would
also argue and i've argued this for you
mike d and aziz are from the same vocal
family
you know what's funny about that guy the
dot um
he the art of speaking what if it turns
out that's john ossoff
he's running for he's gonna lose a lot
of black votes
um it he tried he tried hard
i could tell he did some preparation
he made a choice
that he thought was going to do the work
justice and the certain no
ing i n apostrophe so he's like well i
don't want to whiten it
right so he did the opposite i really
don't fault him my fault whoever
you fought the two black eyes who said
it was cool to be funny
no yeah you're like yeah man that's a
dope-like accent oh god say baby that's
a good accent
hey you're cool okay um so he i whoever
the publisher i mean whoever
somebody listens to it before they allow
it on
i don't know i you know you would think
i bet that it i
it's an art it was an article that's the
thing is
autumn i don't think that was on autumn
but autumn is the is the
audio that you can do audio uh
magazines yeah yeah so this seems like a
smaller version of autumn and i bet at a
certain point they just go
they just trust the engineers to edit it
and not make it
and it just as long as it's not horrible
it was so
funny that it to me it's kind of even
steven's
it's like yes this is very embarrassing
for you
very hilarious for everyone else i don't
think you meant
it to me it's so terrible yeah i'd say
it's a i'd say it's a push
in fact i almost want to say black
people won because it's so entertaining
i think this is a black w that it's like
yo even steven dude like
you're good like don't ruin your life
over there you just
this [ __ ] is young shia labeouf it's
even stephen
um straight up uh this young shia yeah
[Music]
oh this is a different so i don't we
haven't talked about this i don't
think i thought your duh was like ellen
page is turning into a man
duh it was like oh does the next thing
on the on the page
uh ellen page i don't know what to make
of it other than
we went into flamethrowers yeah i'm
sorry
sorry you guys um we'll keep it up in
the
in the in the in the blog as ellen page
and then we just never talk about it
like let's not talk about it uh let's
move on
so you know so you have you heard the
thing i don't know if i talked to you
about this
you know you you can't say like that
person's crazy anymore
i heard that and someone told us when we
were talking about
you mentioned it when we were talking
about kanye the first time right and
you're
saying something crazy say
oh right but yeah but we talked about
crazy is not
okay to say anymore yeah like i was
going crazy
i was oh i thought you meant for you
mean as yourself
you can't even say it as yourself no i
can't what i'm saying is
how to say crazy duh
is not duh is basically you're making
fun
of a mentally challenged person
oh yeah he's like
so look get your does out
what's next okay duh
stupid um do you think they're gonna
come for stupid
i don't know where stupid's or what what
its origins are i don't know
where it where it the flamethrower were
people
where did they come up with stupid just
stupid or stupid origins
um the real meaning of stupid
oh stupid entomology here we go oh okay
get ready everybody get ready
we'll find something came over well and
he he literally googled
stupid entomology which no one's ever
done
overwhelmed from middle french stupidity
16th century mentally slow lacking
ordinary civility of mine
dull or inane went directly from
latin stupidest amazed confounded
dull foolish
i think i think we're gonna allow it i
think we're yeah because i think it's
like
calling someone dull is or dim-witted
i don't think if i say dim-witted i
don't mean
you're i i would only say dim-witted for
someone who
thinks they're smart and is boring i
wouldn't go like
oh his mother fat he dropped him and
he's
if someone was brain injured i wouldn't
go like you know the dim witted
i'm not that mean uh i grew up growing
up one of my best friends her
sister uh was mentally [ __ ]
and i don't think you can say that i
guess if you say mentally you can't no
so that's
so growing up as kids they kind of
taught us
like she's mentally [ __ ] louis did a
whole bit about this
and then they were they told us
she is mentally [ __ ] but she's we
just say special
so we just said special growing up
but technically i i they i was told she
was mentally [ __ ] but she's actually
special so i'm like oh her sister
special that's how we address it and
people were like mean she's a singer or
something
like no she's got like charisma like
she's gonna enter a contest
um see that kind of so we said special
and then it was like special olympics
and
i feel like there's we'd go to these i
think she
i don't know down syndrome um but i
i think that's how the parents because
we'd go to
these events or something for her sister
and everybody used very certain
terminologies
so okay it was just very like a careful
way to address it everybody was being
very careful yes uh so
[ __ ] [ __ ] or [ __ ]
the verb uh it's late 15th century
endomology will's an entomologist no
um uh it makes slow or slower
from french ritardelle uh restrain hold
someone back
keep someone from doing something come
to a stop that's from the 13th century
or directly from latin retired they
make slow get it all out now
that's i i've used the word [ __ ]
like
and they [ __ ] it meaning well i've
used it like in the bad background yard
way
but uh the [ __ ] way meaning like
they hindered it or they
they yeah the growth was [ __ ] yes
yes it was
it was held back or retired they
maybe maybe you say it like that if it's
if it's allowed in other languages yes i
mean
in german it's the hindit hindu well but
that sounds like hindu
behind it yeah like yeah
i mean yes so that's the way like
retarding someone's growth or retarding
someone's progress is
like that's that's viable and it should
be used and it will be used
uh but i remember saying [ __ ] very
loud to my friend
like you're [ __ ] [ __ ] uh in high
school and
a teacher came out i was like do not use
that
that is that and that's been in high
school and i remember i
was 93. thank you
and i was in high school because it was
not hasn't been
born yeah thank you and um yeah she was
like my uncle's [ __ ]
and i was like okay maybe you don't say
it
and then this is the problem people do
though and this is he similar to my
friend because my friends [ __ ]
how similar are they dude we look bring
hey come on over here hey [ __ ] get
over here and then you bring your friend
over and you go
get your uncle on the phone this is
probably the before cell phone but you
go to a pay phone
to have the uncle talk to the friends
this is the [ __ ] up thing
though and i was like okay i'm sorry she
said
you know a long time ago people use
words for black people that they didn't
like
and i was like
okay i didn't need why don't you say it
and see how much longer you teach here
just it's like melanie's joke about the
r the n word
yeah [ __ ] being like the n word and
like well you won't say the n word
so it seems like it's worse than
than [ __ ] i gotta say
um um yeah yeah and even
then i remember telling the story to
someone and saying
i was fully capable of understanding
what she meant without her having to
relate it to me stop saying that
the n word was silent um yeah that the
nines were wild is the point
of that segment uh so da say da now
you're not gonna be able to no you're
not i'm just saying it's you're not
gonna be able to say what can we say
instead of crazy
neil's being uh well the profile is i
just have replaced it in my
i say now brain injured as like as an
insult
yeah but i don't i say like women talk
to guys
women's impression of men make us sound
like we have brain injuries but crazy
doesn't mean brain injury i don't
but uh you can just say like mentally
unwell
now but it's not it's very clinical the
thing about crazy was
it was like that's like yeah like you're
acting crazy you're acting like a little
extra and also crazy is high energy
sounding yeah it's being crazy it's
being crazy
so how do we do he's being duh
i don't know look you're gonna have to
padraig because you're gonna go back
you're on your own just go back
because i don't want to be responsible
for you using these words and then it
turns out
yeah i don't want to be i don't want a
flamethrower don't flamethrow your own
face
is my biggest worry uh weed
bianca yeah weed is now legal
uh in the nba
literally blake texted me because i
asked him
i don't think he smokes weight he i just
like that
the here's the thing about weed tell me
uh this goes to i mean there's
somebody i was i was tweeted but i
texted him a bunch of jokes and they're
like the hackiest jokes
the average score is gonna be like 39 to
20
um somebody i then i like looked them up
i just googled like weed and i just and
someone had someone did a run
and one of them that was [ __ ] really
funny was
the uh the horn is going to scare the
[ __ ] out of the players
which is [ __ ] they've got no retweets
or likes and i was like that's [ __ ]
very funny that's very like i texted but
it was like and he was like that's
[ __ ] like i was like let me just i'm
done but here's one more
um here is my worry
i just it will
help with
it does help with inflammation it helps
with but
there is a downside to weed that
weed advocates act like doesn't exist
which is
weed [ __ ] burns people out weed
dulls it it dulls people's brains i
don't i
i don't think there is a habitual
weed user that uh
hasn't paid i don't know i don't want to
say hasn't prayed
paid some price mentally but i i'll say
this
it's not going to make them better
athletes what it may do
is help with inflammation um
stress of the job i feel like that no
i mean i don't think that i wouldn't say
that it's a stressful job
you don't think that's a stressful job
being an nba player now
why it seems very stressful is being a
comedian a stressful jump do you think
uh no but i feel like there's
this it's so competitive i mean you're
on stage by yourself
you know so if you fail you bomb you
really only let down yourself and maybe
people come to see you whereas
in the in the nba or any sports
you're in a team you have a crowd of
people screaming
well that's where it's similar to comedy
meaning
there's the performance aspect right
um but people aren't having been rooting
for you for generations
should we call blake and ask if he
thinks being an nba is
being in the nba stressful yeah
a guest oh you guys love guests
i love your gifts he picks up this is a
real test
it's a real toast of friendship i don't
often
what if he just pours whatever what if
he forwards it let
us well you got the number you see
everyone can see the number i hope
five five eggs let's video let's um
facetime
[Music]
oh yeah oh oh [ __ ] this is a bonus
topless with a mask hi oh
oh my god
holy [ __ ] oh my god
you're on the podcast live so sorry and
i'll cut it out if you don't want to
well you'll
it whatever the answer we're talking
about the weed
thing right yes
bianca thinks that
being in the nba
is a stressful job i would and i said i
don't think it's a stressful job
regardless of the weed thing would you
consider being
in the nba a stressful job yes
especially if you care if you don't care
then
it might not be that stressful but yeah
it's stressful
okay i would suggest okay
well now i don't want to ask the second
question is how many guys care
it depends on the team but like like our
team our team this year we got a lot of
guys that care like
it feels like you know is that i've been
on teams where
there's there's almost every guy one
through one through you know 15 cares
but i've also been on some teams where
you know not everybody cares and you're
willing to name names
i'm willing to do pen and paper great
bianca well you're on the podcast that's
exciting i have a
wait i have a question so is it what's
the most stressful part
because we're kind of comparing doing
comedy and
being a being
i mean it's sort of the same and like
you sort of get instant gratification or
you get
you get you're used to just like getting
judged pretty much in real time
whether you're doing either you know you
can go you can kill it you can be in the
zone
you can be doing really well or you can
play really really bad
know i think it's like a lot of times
unless it's like a special i guess like
if you just go to the store and you bomb
like not that many people are going to
hear about it but like you know
i would suggest it hurts more than
bombing in practice though
what bombing at the store is worse than
having a shitty practice
oh yeah 100
right but i don't what i'm saying is if
you they're obviously like
the pressure of a big show
like that's obviously there's the
pressure the big show and you're
technically performing for 15 to 20 000
people a night live
plus tv um but i don't
but is that that's not part of the
consideration for weed is that you're
dealing that these guys are dealing with
stress and weed will help them deal with
it most of it's about
i think that the reason they suspected
it now is like listen everybody's like
some of the guys were in the bubble for
a long time
that was stressful it's they're away
from their families this year we're
encouraged
you know to have limited house guests
where
we're encouraged to not really go out to
dinner even on the road
uh we have to have like a pre-approved
nba restaurants when we're on the road
to go eat in so
it's just and that's just the cheesecake
factory by my understanding correct
cheesecake factory
tgi morse
um so i mean i guess they're taking into
consideration that this season is going
to be more stressful
from a mental
like from a mental standpoint just like
you know having limited people around
not having people in the arena we're
playing more games in a shorter amount
of time
um i don't know there's a lot of factors
but i also think that they'll like
probably relax the rule from here on out
even in a regular season
oh yeah they're not going to be able to
they're not going to go back
turn your weed in
where are you uh
you look like you're uh you're no turn
it back
turn it back right now bianca wants that
shirtless
i'm walking in the in our underwater
treadmill
don't mind if i do man if you were on
weed man
if you hand that would be so wild
being on an underwater treadmill man
um
yeah i'm sorry that would have been a
good joke and uh
face i'm [ __ ] it up um so
uh all right the blake griffin with
uh with a uh with a weed
nba weed update i have a question that
you may not want to answer again on the
record is
is there a concern that
it will make the game worse
no i don't think so okay were they
already just
i mean yeah of course god the guys that
we're smoking during games
are we're going to do it anyway yeah the
guys yeah we're going to do it
and they're also probably very good at
it right
they can handle it i guess yep
uh shout out to the people that
anyone who's seen stone during games for
the fan is
is stoned right we can all agree i don't
know
i mean some does seem like it but i
don't think they are
[Laughter]
and that's the saddest part of this
whole thing
um can i be you guys as uh
in the field reporter i would love to
yeah well my god
we'll uh yes we will we'll get back to
you
and you'll see in like two months if you
were like i was wrong
they never should have enacted this
to be a new developer um
all right buddy well it's talk about
caring it's eight o'clock detroit time
and this guy's in the underwater
treadmill
but i gotta get home and smoke a giant
[Laughter]
you [ __ ] all right good all
right buddy good talking
bye you're hot he's
he's going he's he's um that was lovely
um he is uh he's a good
blake griffin is a good boy he's a good
guy i've always said i we i we have a
guy inside that's pretty cool you got a
guy inside
my was talking to my guy 60 days in i'm
not going to say who
um he plays in detroit i had a good joke
about blake which is he
um used to be in the nba and then he
retired to play in detroit you
dick it was it's a ducky joke what's the
timberwolves
no sorry who i don't know uh it is the
pistons
oh yes okay he was by the way blake was
on eric griffin's eric andre's show
this season yeah there's a new season
yeah we broke it up
he looks like where he looks like jeff
it was yeah that's funny he looks like
jeff ross um
the uh the blake
there's something something about blake
going through it made me laugh because i
don't really usually know the people
that are the guests
which is the funny part about the show
yeah like they pick people that wouldn't
like new york from i love new york is on
it um
just like obscure just like obscure oh
marion
yeah they're [ __ ] one blake i don't i
think he went on
i don't know he they weren't he knew
what the show was and he's like
still he's blake's in showbiz
like he's doing well um but
the uh him being scared
was so [ __ ] scared he got scared and
they did
really funny freezes on him that is
really funny i didn't get how i i heard
they make it like
a thousand degrees in there yeah and
they
uh some will have like a shocker on them
or there was one
actor who they just kept dripping like
one job it's so funny
it's so funny it's such a funny show
it's one of my favorite shows um
it's so it's definitely my top 25 of all
time
i can just he just goes he's
on the street [ __ ] i cannot burn up
one i didn't realize that bird up was a
play on ward up
he says bird up as the guy in the sprite
the sprite guy oh the like the black
sprite guy
no there's it he when he says bird i
don't know what this is right guys
yeah the sprite it's like four springs
but it's so [ __ ]
funny and i assume doug pound writes
every pun
because doug pound from the champs what
is works in the show
does he yeah he's like in the credits
and
writes for it and they did a behind the
scenes one and he was in it this
season but it's it's so doug's sense of
humor
oh okay to say bird up i can't even
explain it it's also duck
so so dead uh so blake uh so
his thing about teams
he would obviously he knows better than
both of us right
i also think
there are certain lies he has to tell i
you know what that's why
i stop myself from asking something
because i'm not filtering it for
i know him i don't i don't know
i i don't think he just lied to us but
it's like he's lying but he's
you know it's his job and he doesn't
want to go like yeah
he can't say it's going to be worse yeah
can you imagine
and also yeah and i think he would say
that um that
that he we're i think he's right about
if you were smoking weed before you're
gonna smoke weed now
yeah there's people who smoke weed and
exercise and everyone's like how the
[ __ ] do you do that but they're
it is funny that like these guys are
gonna be isolated we should have them
smoke weed that'll probably
what i was gonna say yeah
have you smoked weed what i was going to
say was that
they knew they were all smoking weed
it's a little it's not insulting i know
it's
but there's the majority of black
players in the nba and it's like you
know what they're going through tough
times let's give them weed
like let's let's just put a like a malt
liquor under their tree
it's more than malt like it's like we
should give them weed you know what else
we should give them to cope with this
free sneakers because i think that's
really going to help like no they
already have that
they're good the the
the the the idea that they're they're
gonna
he he's he's not wrong he's not wrong
that guys were smoking we're smoking now
it is an odd thing it's a weird thing
it's a what's weird is it's legal in
10 states now but not all the states are
there right so
if i live in if i play for portland
and it's everything's illegal in oregon
now by the way
which i i mean which i i'm gonna try to
get a law passed
in for washington state uh
and in california that if you're
if if you have drugs in your car and a
cop pulls you over
if you can floor it to oregon and make
it across the border
it's the duke's called the dukes of
hazard law where if you get to oregon
they can't they can't do [ __ ] that's
good so that's what i'm gonna be
spending the next few years on
i'm dedicating my life to that my cause
moving on oh this is separately and uh
and uh not not [ __ ] until
coincidentally
there's a you know there's a bunch of
apps for when you get pulled over which
i feel like we've touched on or maybe we
never did
but we are
yeah there's roaches in the precinct we
all know it and this is
this is roach repellent this is raised
what do they do uh they're they're
perhaps that record but
one of them now
goes live to local law lawyers
wow one of them goes to your family like
if someone is on
is it needs meds or something someone's
having a bipolar episode or someone's
having
any kind of episode it goes to so if the
family is like
he's not crazy this is blake tell me to
cut it no i'm kidding
um uh that could be embarrassing
no thank you uh the live stream scares
me
it's not to like everyone but
now now of course the caveat is that
that that guy got shot on facebook live
so
i think that uh i
again it's just a step in the right
direction it's great mobile justice
legal equalizer
uh to capture the entire interaction
with police know your rights and make
sure your loved ones know where you are
so it'll tell you so you just pre-plan
like hey send this to
yeah or and it also there's one where
like it gives you
tips as it's happening like what your
rights are
no one knows the rights no one knows our
rights i don't think
and i think they also vary
from state to state they i don't i don't
know who i don't know what my rights are
i don't either one time i didn't want to
sign the thing
because it was such [ __ ] so i don't
have to sign that he's like yeah you do
i'm like okay
like i don't want to i'm going to argue
you folded
yeah i was like no one did a picnic
uh yeah the the so
they call again legal equalizer and
mobile justice and i'm sure i need this
bug assault right now
i know i need to shoot you bianca i
wouldn't shoot you in the face
unless the mop was near unless i thought
it was gonna come to every
episode bug assault um
know your rights um
i don't know what uh
but so if you're if you're if you're
first of all if you're black or brown
get it
get one of these great i don't think
it's gonna hurt you there's one where
even if the cop
uh breaks your phone it like oh that's
great right to the cloud
again if you just type in one of them
you'll get all of them on the app store
uh legally equalizing or mobile justice
or of course just get bug assault focus
i'll just shoot the cop
um well
you got a song for doc watch
[Music]
doc there's a there's a
there's a website called uh
i i it used to be called streaming where
okay
where uh you type in a movie that you
want to watch
there's so many [ __ ] platforms now
it's so crazy you mean to
is to see what's streaming where um
you look it up just watch yeah it's just
it used to be just watch
and then it maybe it is just watch all
right so it's just watch
so i do just watch okay um and i caught
up and you just
do you just click by the way just watch
is not
well run meaning if you do top 10 if you
do like documentaries
by genre um
it it'll have like [ __ ] that's not that
aren't
documentaries if you do uh
yeah well uh it's not you didn't do it
it's okay
yeah um it's just the job so it'll but a
lot of [ __ ] will come up where it'll be
like
not a duck it's not a documentary it's
it's some it's like 42 just came up
the jackie robinson it's like that
wasn't a documentary sorry to tell you
um uh anyway uh
i watch one well it's actually getting
worse
um uh you just shut it down well goodbye
um
oh michael hutchins from nxs
i don't know if you remember in excess i
do remember
um i want to [ __ ] you like an animal
nope
uh same that [ __ ] you like an animal's
trap master
what is niner snails uh in excess
um oh i need you tonight yes
yes but you're not wrong you could do a
nice mashup okay
um you're not wrong they might have done
a nice mashup well
um uh the document is called mystify
it's on amazon and i was surprised
by how good it was i know he has a wild
life
he wasn't his first of all he dated
helena christensen
for four years helena christensen which
if you're gonna
build a woman helena christensen in her
prime
i would argue the baddest
baddest woman who ever lived just looks
wise for
me again i'm not getting into
now when it helena christensen in
like eight she was in the chris isaac
yeah like
she's so good-looking to me uh
it's it's just insane
um so uh anyway they dated for a while
didn't he die am i tripping yes he died
but
they he hung himself but then it was
like
everybody said it was an autoerotic
asphyxiation
um there was just a lot of mitigating
things but the story is
i won't give it away but it's it's uh
way more nuanced and it's
um [ __ ] up and
sad and it's basically an
accident that took place
that whatever he he he only
he died uh he was like age 30.
no he was 37 not old
um so yeah so
watch it it was good doc could have been
bad wasn't
uh the one thing i did notice though
this is from the people who brought you
uh
people doing characters
um is when
musicians try to do
athletic things in concert or
videos just like jumping and you see
like their vertical is like
an inch and a half and you're like i
don't know dog you didn't need to do
that i'm not
i don't like your music more now in fact
i like it a lot less
based on you thinking that that was
gonna look cool
and how awful it looked especially photo
shoots they'll jump around
and you're just like uh no i just need
to see the photos
don't show me how you got there have you
ever seen
comedy style headshots you know when
they
they
they are the worst to me it's like why
are we you don't need a rubber chicken
well funny and this happened to me
tina fey always said they photographers
always want to
give comedians they want to make
comedians hold a rubber chicken
every time like without fail across time
but so many people
have been yeah i mean
i but i did a hollywood reporter story
like a year and a half ago
and the guy had me get on stage and tie
myself
up in the mic and it was like i couldn't
explain to him
did you say no i could it just
i couldn't begin to explain to him why
it was bad
so i just did it and tried to express
with my face i know
this is bad like in the photo in the
photo
i'm sorry guys uh will you can bring it
up
neil brennan hollywood reporter uh
yeah these are this one this is the one
where i was
like all right i know this is bad
i knew it was bad but i just tried to
get across like
i know this is bad but
the not much i can do here gang um
so that's interesting uh but yeah tina
said and then i
did a and then another guy i did a photo
shoot recently
and the guy wanted
uh he's like i want to get i want
the guy too the guy had a bad idea that
i was like don't do that
and he shot it's the best photographer
i've ever worked with dominic
something and i don't know his name and
wait so did he force the
bad idea because i just said hey man i
know
uh that you think this is
maybe that's it i don't think that's it
but um
no but anyways
even a good even his first instinct he
ended up getting
i ended up doing one as a mascot it's
just that they don't know what they
don't know
sometimes like he wanted to do one where
i was a mascot
and and i had like he took
really good [ __ ]
like i like no that's good what do you
mean no they're the best photo i've ever
had but
great great oh they're great
yeah let's let's and then this one
that one's good oh yeah i like though
yeah like he did it was great but
he did one as the mascot and i was like
you know
you gotta worry about it no no that's
funny though it's funny but it's like no
it's silly it's like but i said like
well i gotta worry about kanye's album
because that's like the only time
someone's been a mascot in like
popular things and he was like oh i
didn't he just didn't know about it so
they i don't think that they have bad
instincts necessarily
but the other ones were funny and
interesting yeah but and then
he got and then there were some that
were like the mascot one i don't mind
they're like i did one that was funny i
like the mascot one with your head
off then yeah i did one where i'm the
where i'm like laying like yeah there's
a sexy mascot
well of course i'll send these because
people are going to be riveted by this
pictures of me and then i have some
other pictures when did you take those
month and a half ago maybe why because
he just dm me he was like hey man i want
to
shoot you and that's cool oh cool he's
like i'm just a fan and i wanted to
take pictures great he rented the studio
and everything was [ __ ] perfect
yeah um gave me something to do during
covet of course i got coveted
which was a small price to pay for those
some hot picks
um so is heaven's gate out
i haven't skate is out as of yesterday
okay so it's heaven it's called the full
title it's on hbo max
but you can't this is what i'm talking
about the confusion of finding it
what do you mean i went on
so i heard us on hbo max so i go on hulu
and there's an hbo max button on hulu
but yours doesn't couldn't find it
then i'm look i go on just what i
whatever you have to go through hbo mac
you have to go through the
front door of hbo max on hbomax.com or
whatever your [ __ ] happens yeah
here's my issue with heaven's gate okay
that's hillbilly that's hello yeah hail
bob yes
okay um t and t and t
and toe or something were their names
the two they would call himself
in some ways every
cult story is the same uh
it's a guy that was disgraced in a
former life
starts uh some kind of psychic psychotic
episode and comes out of it and
starts a cult and then ultimately [ __ ]
everybody yeah
uh in this one maybe he castrated i
can't remember i even got that first oh
castrated people maybe that's sick and
weird
yeah maybe um but uh my god
so i only watch one episode so oh it's
episodic
yeah i love it yeah uh
they tried it and then the patient
almost died but
and one person left so they were like
yeah maybe we'd give it a rest
um so um so
i don't want
what i'm not gonna say it was boring but
it was it's just a bit
rote at this point and the way the
documentary was
set up the timeline was a little hard to
follow
and so i only watched the most
linear timeline like how was it uh
interesting that
because they did flashbacks and they i'm
not saying
every documentary should do what the
the the bulls one the last dance did
where they literally went like
1996. calendar not they didn't do a
calendar but they went like
like it's just now we're 96 and we're
going back in time everyone to 93.
in the last dance to me it
you kite it was all one year kind of
yeah like
it didn't ultimately matter this is a
bit there's flashbacks and who people
are and
i might have been getting you know sort
of lost in my own thoughts
somewhat but so no but a documentary
layout
for understanding for the takeaway fully
understanding the situation is really
important it's necessary but
many but they but a lot of it's so
embedded
that you don't notice that they did a
lot for you to follow along
yeah i think ezra ezra did did great i
mean
amazi i mean for example that's where i
made the greatest doc oh j magnum
but even like a graphic of a me
yeah that helps because otherwise it's
like
yeah how or sometimes it's it's simple
but it's just
boring or not or yeah i
it's just the pace i think there's
something to be said for i think
in some ways ezra may have [ __ ]
[ __ ] up the game by everyone yeah
they can't well i gotta do at least
seven episodes
in order to tell this story i need seven
episodes like
you need three yeah between you and me
you need three
um but that's the it like it's the
filmmaker
and i also in the on the positive i
think documentaries are so
uh respected now and so popular they
really do well in the ratings that
they're like [ __ ] yeah we'll take
another last dance
you want to do 20 like you want to just
cover steve
kerr when last dance ended dudes didn't
know what to do with themselves they
were like
so many people died so many people
killed themselves
um so i may
give the second episode a try that's you
know here's the problem with episodics
is that if you don't get it right in the
first episode i'm not watching the rest
whereas i'll watch a whole documentary
and just be like whatever but you
you get you know i did the thing i
watched the whole documentary so
it's good for the filmmakers or
whoever's streaming it but if you're
trying to think of the vowel
suffered from i stopped the problem with
the vowel was
apparently the other one that came out
apparently there's two is
great yeah and everyone's like that
one's i hope they make an animated
series out of it i hope they really blow
it up children
children's books and all kinds of merch
um i watch the one
murder on the myrtle
myrtle on yeah myrtle on myrtle myrtles
on myrtles noodles on myrtles
um myrtle myrtle murder on myrtle
beach something uh it was
i i got a lot from the first i got
enough
i don't got it i got i'm sure there's a
twist
i'm sure there's a thing but it was
you'll never know
i'm like dude listen if you're gonna do
a long murder on middle beach oh there
we go
there's no myrtle uh if you're gonna do
a date like leave dateline to dateline
because that sounds like a title of a
dateline episode a 48 hour mystery sort
of thing like it was murder on little
beach
it just was like a long date line just
leave dateline to dateline or
do something really it's just like a son
trying to solve his mom's murder
but yeah which is fine but it i don't
know
um i don't i don't i think that
some things are
you know not everything needs a
documentary not everything needs a
podcast not everything needs just
their people as as
whenever i think there's so much i was
just going through
all my platforms yesterday i was like
this is way too much [ __ ]
like sorry everybody i'm not gonna watch
all this [ __ ]
uh now if i'm a network i need
programming
so i get where they're coming i get
where everybody's coming from if i'm a
person i want money
i want to film i want to make movies i
want to so i
who [ __ ] knows but now
the documentary the donkey series that
i'm making i'm gonna need your full
support on
this is neil neil's like too many
clothes we cannot flute the earth
but i'm gonna make sure you're gonna
make some shirts let me tell you
something
it's different bianca yeah it's
different than what i do it's different
yeah yeah buddy buddy um i'm making a
documentary about the making of being
kevin hart's chase
bank commercial the also no one
thinks it's chase people
anyone who tweets about it it's always
capital one i know it's a very capital
one
esque and you did it well it's not like
maybe you've gleaned
it's bright but what what it it's
basically
chase's version of a capital one card
which is giving you money back
so i don't know that's you're going to
deep with it
that's the card not the commercial style
i don't
the capital one is like me to me it's
like
alec baldwin jimmy fallon capital one
feels like
good nights capital one feels like those
airplane videos they play you know the
where they put production value into
yes i'm like oh welcome to uic maybe man
they make it like
interesting or something capital one
feels like that chase feels like that
kevin
how does chase feel you're saying this
chase but it's like it's kind of fun and
funnier it's charming that's what kind
of commercials charmander
wow charmity bank baby that's an old
mike shure
told me that term 20 years ago his
friends were working in advertising
so charmity
it seems like chase is way more sterile
it's always like when you're on the run
and you want it what's the well the
thing i always say about these
commercials is
why would a publicly traded company
character all you do do is right but why
would they cause i
made a version of that commercial that's
genuinely funny that i think i showed
you
yeah it's genuinely fun but they didn't
do it they didn't use it because
why well you're proving my point
why bother why bother being the
republican trader company
comedy inherently has some risk in it
you're gonna hurt somebody's feelings if
you don't believe me ask david sedaris
um so you know
why bother there are some brands that
are [ __ ]
make legitimately funny commercials and
it's part of their
just a part of their brand geico for 20
years
for 20 years they even did a best of
they literally just replay their old
[ __ ]
yeah liquor so what i'm saying is
you're forgetting how much if you make
me laugh
i'm gonna buy your product more it's
just hacking people i don't know if
that's true but you think i mean
straight up comedy and i just mean
light-hearted
charmity as you're saying right but i
don't get it but i think
if it matches your brand that people
think geico is successful because
they're commercial funny
geico's successful because they buy more
advertising than
anyone on earth right and they're
absolutely look at the number yeah but
like they just their inventory is
massive so
but they're not the most popular uh
insurance which is funny
well because they don't use um allstate
like the all-state guy or
chris whoever chris what's the you know
who i wanted to give a shout-out to i
keep meaning to and never do
alfonzo robero is so goddamn funny in
the
chris paul commercials he's legitimately
like that [ __ ] is funny i don't
i i never watch fresh prince
you didn't watch when he was on not one
episode did i watch
oh my god you're missing culture i
realized that we
did a joke on the entrepreneur that from
the fresh prince
that and i had no idea i saw a clip and
i was like oh we
did that on stole it yeah basically
inadvertently stole it and i'm sure dave
didn't see it i'm sure i didn't see it
where dave there's four microphones and
dave goes shut the [ __ ]
up will had done that on the first
principle right
that's how little we watched anyhow
did you see the oh well then you
probably haven't seen the reunion i've
seen the carlton dance obviously very
funny
you didn't see the reunion i didn't it
would make no sense to you
it was very good i almost had a
highlight in your life
i got kind of invited on the red table
talk
what you mean this red table no a
different red
a different red dead or more popular one
oh my god are you going
i don't want to blow it shut the [ __ ] i
don't
i don't know but if you think i'm not
going to get to the bottom of
if i'm not going to drop dime on that
will smell everything i know about them
um that's actually a good doc watch the
the fresh prince of bella reunion is so
is it docky it's all doc okay all right
i'll watch that because i didn't know
they bring together they talk about
kind of how it was a lot of good
flashbacks it it sucks because
if you watch the show and it means
something to you it's
it is very sad because it's you
they talk about like james avery and the
read over that all that
but they you know the battle between
dark-skinned lights cannot viv
and will and her had a very bad falling
out for many years and so
he she i saw those clips
but the whole interview especially with
her is so
it's so good it's so good will is just
gonna be a self-help person
and probably if you think he's gonna
play support
in a movie you're out of your mind
he's either gonna be the lead of a movie
or
he's going to play just he's either
going to be the lead
or he's just going to be some kind of
self-help guru
yeah well he in this one it was really
interesting because
will is so beloved and it's always so
nice and smiling
and it was interesting to see somebody
kind of pay out to him wait
no be on bianca if you're telling me
that people
nobody in show business makes it by
accident it seems like you're telling me
that people that
make it to the top are very ambitious
yes
it's but again i thought it was just
natural charisma
over and over again if you're mean to
tell me that someone like will smith
is cutthroat and or
[Music]
deceitful sometimes
you're blowing my [ __ ] mind right now
believe it or not
he wasn't always the freshest prince off
off camera and to have someone
pay out to him straight up and be like
you took everything away from me
[Music]
and it was like
you can tell that at that moment at this
part in his life he could
he is has all the skills to be able to
handle that conversation i don't know if
it would have turned out so great like
any other like if he was younger
i think he kind of said that in it right
he said about him in the show but i'm
saying i don't know if he could have
done
a reunion i don't know it just seemed
like will
was in a position to like really accept
responsibility
he's a he i don't know if i've said this
on the show but
he takes money that he makes
for all the [ __ ] he does and then he
like just does [ __ ] personal
self-help [ __ ] as a guy like that's his
like he just he he like he takes the
money
i mean not like all but whatever like
yeah he invests in himself
like a lot of people hey i like that i
like this book i read
i'm gonna fly that person to come and
stay here for a week
right a doctor or a like he's a he's a
he's uh he's trying to uh
grow as a person beyond
um stardom
right and it almost never happens no
no or they most they don't stay in
hollywood well
he what do you mean i mean a lot of
people i think who
go down to self-help it's rare to find
someone who's still very successful
still in hollywood also on a path of
self-help those two things i feel like
sometimes
it's usually like i was in a horrible
boating accident
and i had to overreach like there's
always something yeah
there's a catalyst for it he didn't
really have a catalyst other than
it's like oprah that kind of like are
you doing yoga
well yeah it's uh image uh rehab
basically is why people will didn't have
much of a
thing to he didn't need to rehabilitate
anything other than like
jada kind of said like they all were
kind of like you're a [ __ ]
dick not exactly but like
they had they talked about it in their
red table yeah not mine
um they talked about it where like he
had a sort of yeah like they were like
yeah
we don't like this yeah and he talked
about on the jay-z thing i made with
made like three years ago yeah but he is
a
he [ __ ] tries which is he tries and
that's
he's you know like doing better than
most people in hollywood
at his success level also trying to be a
good person
actively putting their [ __ ] out there i
mean
we
and just took it like a g and and
made it i don't think anyone even the
the most like hardcore like man i
wouldn't let my lady
yeah there's a lot of that there's so
much of that for a week but then
now it's like okay now it's like all
right well first of all
you know the peop people's metabolism is
so fascinating they're just like what
happened
i know i was like his name was a jake
augustus yeah who's his name
um that's funny uh yeah like
who knows you don't even remember it
uh august alsina augustus klimp
for all intents and purposes um
so i don't know why we talked about this
oh because
will um fresh prince owning us
yes um i avoided watching it because and
it was
really it was really it's good it's a
feel good it gets a little
emo in parts but you end up reliving
it's just it's go i think you should
watch it because even if you're not
you don't need to be a fan of the show
to get something i'll watch it because
i'm
i like believe in will as a
believer like he [ __ ] needs my help
but i want to make a documentary about
him
yeah so this is good that would be a big
part like
market research i'm sure somebody else
will make it but but
listen start the bid start the video
well he wants
you're not gonna believe he wants me to
do something for him before he'll do
that for me
a lot of these oh you know hollywood a
lot of these hollywood people
they need something from you before you
as if
it's not all for him um uh
and then i watched called after
innocence
which is on showtime was that the
innocence project
it's yeah it follows the lives of the
dudes after they
are exonerated hmm sad
super not a uplifting i thought it was
going to be great like maybe they would
have been better off
still in jail i mean not that but not
that they would have been better off
not getting exonerated that's what i
mean because
i didn't know that when you get on
parole
there's tons of government funding for
you there's a halfway house there's
mental health help there's job
stuff whereas with i think i know what
you're gonna say and i it's so
when you're exonerated you get nothing
they're just like
bye you this never happened don't tell
anyone yeah
um but and also they're also conv
there's a conviction on the record and
they can't get it expunged and
a lot of them have stories of like well
uh pay
me six thousand dollars and we'll
expunge the record what
yeah so they so they can't get jobs
um a lot of them it was like
so much it's all based on obviously dna
evidence with the innocence project for
the most part
and years of trying to get certain dna
tested
and then they finally get it tested they
get off
but the fight that the that the state
puts up against testing it
and then won't test and then there's one
guy who
not a very effective he doesn't have a
very effective means of getting the word
out
he just goes to like a square where
people are trying to eat their lunch and
it's like
i was ex you know just not good in the
hands out leaflets but
he's saying that there was dna in his
case that he was
um he was exonerated through his dna it
wasn't him there was dna out there that
he
that the state could just put into the
fbi database
to see if it gets any hits back so they
can try to solve it
and they will not test the dna they have
um it just was it's that weird thing of
like
we got the conviction so why would we do
that no we got to because it's wrong
well no but we already it's just been
served it's just too expensive why
bother why bother we got technically
we it's like plea bargains like but we
got the play bargain so why the [ __ ]
would we undead it's done yeah there was
one
guy that's that the um
the judge said to the the prosecution
do you want so this man is going to be
exonerated and you want to bar him from
getting
any compensation and the
prosecutor is like yes that's he's like
it's my understanding that you want to
just
prevent him from getting any
compensation
for being put away for like 20 years 10
years something like that
you're like yeah that is that's where we
stand in the judge's like jaw dropped
apparently that was the story but it
just
it's not about justice it's about we
invested time
we put you away it was expensive this
whole thing is expensive and
bureaucratic
so losing that really is a bummer it's
not so much
about the right guy it's about it's
about
like moving paper yeah and now we have
that pile of paper
got into another pile of paper and like
but it's we already moved the paper
it's scary why the [ __ ] would we yeah
it's and
you're not going to tell me that most
these guys are black are you there was a
there was some white stuff right now i
know but in the dark
like it was like it was mostly black and
more white than i thought more white
than i expected
i just realized that i could have
and should have facetime will smith when
we were talking about him really
i know what's funny is why did you blake
you go
yeah [ __ ] call him but will smith
it's like let's respect this time
no i'm just like i don't know riff and
with will
like he wouldn't thank you i think he
might pick he probably would pick up
but i don't want to i he he if he ever
does the punch what an ambush though oh
my god would he i would
only want to i would only want him to
i would want him to tell people his self
help
right ethos that would i wouldn't be i
would just say in two minutes
tell people yourself help eat those but
if he did the podcast
yeah i mean we wouldn't need a you know
we wouldn't need to go interview him
about his life i mean we get him
everyone knows will no yeah but i don't
everybody knows but it's more a matter
of just
you just want you're like this is the
thing i like about them i want other
people it's like chris it's like i want
people to know what
a maniac chris is more than anything
a maniac and a drizzle
exactly a grizzle detective it's a
legitimate the best song
and again no disrespect to eric johnson
um so like this was wasted on this could
have been on it
it could have been honest it could have
been on the record it could have been on
the
radio is that of radio do people still
listen to the record radio uh
separately errol morris quickly
made a dot called my psychedelic love
story he did that
yes did you watch it no i was going to
watch it i'm too much
timeline-wise it's a nightmare and it
would have been
very easily fixed and they just didn't
visually as good a documentary as you'll
ever see
wow i mean you want to talk about arrow
more is really good with cutaways
he only uses like an obscure [ __ ]
he's used
obscure [ __ ] it's
it's it's a cutaway it's a it's a cut
it's a
it's a cutaways playground it's
color palette and cutaways
bellissimo it's
so good you can't believe how good it is
um
is it better than like the ayahuasca art
it's in that palette oh well it's but
it's more
um because it's about an lsd okay so
it's in that palette but
have you done lse yeah lsd
is like mushrooms on acid
and it is it is acid so it's it's a
funny metaphor
um it's great it's
it's just a great it's visually amazing
which
often doesn't happen in documentaries
hopefully it'll happen in my
will smith documentary and my
non-existent will smith documentary
um soul of america is a documentary
about uh uh journalist
john meacham which shouldn't be i know
he's an msnbc guest he's one of these
guys who does a hundred speaking
engagements a year at least that you
would
never know and probably makes
four million dollars a year public
speaking and he's not like
be i wouldn't you'd never know it um so
it's a combination of his speaking
engagements
plus uh it's contextualizing
modern history versus american history
and it's way better than it should be
he's pretty engaging
he's a square but pretty engaging and uh
and he's [ __ ] knowledgeable [ __ ] so
it's like oh cool so it's
worth watching it's on hbo max or
someone somewhere best of luck finding
it but if you do you're in for a real
treat
soul of america sounds like it's about
black people
it's about a powerfully white white men
uh do you watch
scripted shows anywhere
by any more i mean not since family ties
went off the air
in 1990 um
okay because i've never watched i
watched it that's the only sitcom i've
watched and it's relatively interesting
i just mean the uh
there's one called your honor with brian
cranston i saw the
trailer it's in new orleans and i don't
know
anyways whatever you do well what's the
premise is it
he's a judge he's a judge with a drug
problem no he's a judge
and his son um
i don't know there's something happened
at a in the black part of new orleans
to his son's girlfriend he's going to
commemorate it on the
anniversary simultaneously there's a
rich kid
driving like of a mob boss's son driving
a motorcycle and um
he hits and kills the sun this happens
very quickly so don't worry
he goes to his dad he's like i think i i
i hit and ransom when i left the scene
and i think he's dead and then brian
cranston is basically like
he does this in the middle of a
courtroom right he walks into the middle
of a
hearing he goes dead dead can i talk to
you for a second
the bailiffs like should i have who go
ahead
and he tells him son gets into the jury
into the into the witness box and he
goes dad
start going and he goes and then
he's like we gotta turn you in son so he
goes and
they go to the precinct and he realizes
who the who the son's dad is and he's
like get back in the car
and then he's like we can't we're gonna
never talk about this again
but i'm sure there's so many little
things that got there's just they're
gonna piece together the story again
it's not over
no but i didn't i didn't i don't know i
have issues with it but
well you don't watch well there's
there's [ __ ] there was a judge
like a judge got sentenced oh you could
do like a bat
like a dirty judge like a dirty judge
like a dirty uh what was it it would
judge like
hit some it was recently i feel like we
talked about but it was something where
judges oh it was the judge's son got
killed by
a someone they sentenced no
well there's those stories then there's
also the thing that judges
give worse sentences before lunch i feel
like maybe we should do that a series
about that
are you serious yes they if you see a
judge you're better off seeing a judge
you're so much better
off seeing a judge at 2 30 than 12 30.
12 30
the sentences are worse because human
beings are [ __ ]
incredibly fallible wow and the whole
system the irrational hungry judge
judges are more lenient after taking a
break
so anyhow anyway that's a whole other
problem
um this one is a long oh i this is
just prepping the emails well
[Music]
all right so we got a lot of emails
about
islam oh yeah and
an audio one let's do it
man neil's i mean there's a really
long one i mean there's it's people are
split ultimately
and maybe and people are split these are
long they're too long
what i'm saying is play the christian
play the audio one you've got mail hey
milan bianca big fan of the show
um last week you were talking about uh
liberals and kind of ignoring the
conservative parts of christie of islam
um isn't it that islam isn't that much
of a threat here it's more christianity
uh at least in america conservative
christianity is far bigger of a threat
with uh you know them basically trying
to ban abortion in every state
amy cody barrett being part of a group
called the handmaids our supreme court
justices getting picked by a guy in opus
dei
uh it just feels like that's way more of
a threat to me than
uh islam will ever be and to me it's
more we should stop
tearing apart muslim countries and
murdering them and leave them alone to
figure out their own problems
and things that they might not like and
then yeah
that's just how it works but that's my
thought thanks for the show
all right so what this comes down to in
in in my reading of all these letters
and
and you know i do some pretty scholarly
stuff
about these subjects and really well
reversed and i do of course
really preserve the french [ __ ]
library
i go to a library card go to a library
uh here's my question overall so
what i would say is liberals are against
christianity kind of openly
they're not they're against a lot of it
and christians are against islam
but the irony of course is that
the difference between islam and christ
fundamentalist islam and fundamentalist
christianity
is are not very far apart in terms of
the outcomes they they seek if you're
talking about the actual
like the text right
it's uh christianity's had a reformation
but the people the opus dei and all that
[ __ ]
is still pretty conservative
so christian i'm sorry so liberals in
america are
against christianity but they're
for islam right and what i'm saying is
hey
liberals they're not that different
right
the big question is for all this stuff
is
what does a muslim country
look like and what what like
whether it's sudan
or on the one hand like like
a failed state there's a there's a
there's a spectrum there's there's
sudan there's saudi arabia there's
turkey
there's um croatia
yugoslavia that whatever the the former
yugoslavia
what can can
uh western democracy
and
islam peacefully coexist
that's and i feel like what you answered
last week so try
if you can avoid it this week see what
you can do
you were either said explicitly or were
implying like
welp too late because you guys
uh made made uh colonies of all these
places
and the chickens are coming home to
roost etcetera what i'm saying is
can is france even though is france
right to be afraid of
is like is it growing islam gonna run
is it just gonna get lo once it be let's
say it gets to fifty percent
right which it'll be a while but
demographically
no it's five percent no no but i'm
saying
there's the things where like muslims
are are are uh
uh having more children than any other
it's that type [ __ ] where it's like
right would
a muslim country
be pro-democracy and
and anti-theocracy
that's what i'm saying what i'm saying
is i think i i
there are so few just openly democratic
muslim countries
it seems like they veer toward theocracy
and if it's if you're a western country
uh would a theocracy not
are they not are they right for it to
scare them a little bit
my issue with everything you're saying
one
you have a bit that is literally
that would answer your own [ __ ] the bit
about the jay-z dude i don't watch my
own accent i mean clearly
i don't care but a lot of that humor
stuff's not funny you have a bit that
literally could just come in and speak
to you we are all trying to change our
foreign policy for this [ __ ]
that knows all the words of jay-z i mean
you are literally answering your thing
so it's hard for me to understand how
but i'm saying that
i'm talking about the the muslim in
america and the guy
mentions rami and and moammar
um as cool
american muslims who make it seem like
the more extreme parts of islam
uh is are not
real or not because i for for every
mo and rami there's a cleric who's like
no i'll tell you what islam yeah but
what i one i don't understand why you're
concentrating on the extremist behavior
of islam because it doesn't represent
all of islam and you know it because you
have to know what to write that [ __ ]
of course i mean my point is like muslim
muslims are not the joke is that most
i'm sure you've all very classic meals
best
album um is that most muslims are not
good muslims
much like most christians are not good
christians it's i think it's probably
that's not the joke yeah it is no the
joke is that uh
there are very rare uh christians who
know
every [ __ ] rhyme right away every
part of the bible the way they there's a
guy at jay-z show who knows every lyric
there's a guy right
there's fewer muslims like that
than than you than most muslim western
yeah exactly exactly but if you
are going to sit there and say like i
don't get why you're concentrating on
muslim extremists because they're
extremists in everything and that's just
that's just based on religion like we
can concentrate
on an extreme behavior of any stereotype
of a certain race
of a certain like gender let's start
with dominicans
okay let's go all love
timberland but not the real timberlands
like the off-brand
villains that are more like snakery boot
sneakers it's fine um
so i just feels like
you know the basis of this country is
you know obviously this
free from persecution everybody come
bring everybody you're religious
race gender creed color all that
[ __ ] but you're really concentrating
on
for me like a non-threatening factor
which is
and and if we take it out of islam and
we put it to anything else i don't i
think you'd agree it sounds a little bit
ignorant
i i don't disagree like oh the
you know the mexicans are having more
babies that it's like
there's right that what i might counter
would be
that there is no that i can think of
there is no christian saudi arabia
there is no christian you know what i
mean like there are no other
uh country you could i if you if you go
with america
america again there's been a reformation
your
women don't have to cover up in public
like there are things
or and then there's like female genital
mutilation there's a lot of stuff in
that's i believe fairly popular
and fairly accepted parts of
uh islam in especially in the middle
east
and probably northern africa that
i just i don't know that's where i get
like i don't know
i just don't think that um
the unit of measure of whether there's a
good example of a country out there that
also has like a good healthy democracy
is what religion dominates that country
because there's plenty of examples
of [ __ ] [ __ ] democracies out here
that are catholic or chris or
have christian roots and so i just don't
think
to contradict my joke a little bit and
counter what you're saying the fact that
there was a reformation in christianity
makes everyone go like jesus
but there are like you cannot really
drink in iran
it is a great but that's what i'm saying
like
they take there is no like there are
there is no the
alcohol literally it's in the it's it's
the rubbing alcohol it's just vodka they
just go home and drink it everyone
eh okay i hear contradictory things on
that where it's like
wait but what does that mean sorry i
don't understand you don't really have
to do it dude every
human beings do what human beings are
going to do and they don't
only abide by religious laws you think
people don't
have pre-marital sex and party in iran
i of course of course they do but i hear
varying story i'm it's all anecdotal
from my point of view
no for sure but i do wonder when we take
it from like oh like whatever
to anecdotal land to put it
and use it to try to understand
the ethnocentric views of french
parisians
yeah i would yes i would say if you just
go
the west right so all of europe a lot of
europe
and america canada whatever
what is the
there are there are a lot of countries
were based i mean america is based on
religious freedom
wink wink wink wink winning but we're
working with christianity right
rising uh uh
but northern node yeah like there are
not i i don't there's a there are
you're right to point out there there
are not many democracies period
um to not have
a
it seems like if the if the uh
royal family was booted in in saudi
arabia
i feel like some sort of cleric would be
not would be
uh given the job you know what i mean
what's the point of that my point is
it's they're
short i feel like if they if they
they would like religious they want a
religious specifically muslim
leader and laws who's they it seems like
the majority of middle eastern muslim
countries
with with muslim citizens would like
a uh some sort of muslim
basis for laws and and then the basis
for the law is how many of these are we
going to use
right some are like iran i would assume
iran iraq iraq i don't he i don't think
he's not a cleric obviously
but there's a big clerical fight there
for who who would be in charge right i
mean iraq is in a really rough state
because they
they you know unfortunately saddam how
we favored them
but saddam was like keeping a lid down
but as long as saddam was doing good in
terms of
like i mean we can criticize in
this piece first but he was doing it by
killing the opposition any time they
even so much raised their hand exactly
and that was his opener
you know i was [ __ ] over the opening
um no
listen the middle east and a lot of
parts of africa and asia
have a lot of issues but i feel like we
overly
focus on them and link them so closely
and we tether them to the religion
whereas
russia is not a super religious country
and it's still [ __ ]
i
personally i think it's countries that
have a lot of oil
or a lot of resources and um
but i think and you when you get into
africa that falls apart because they
don't they're
but they have resources they have like
they have resources that's there's a
reason why
i don't think as many resources but
sudan is like
is the la is a failed state is it but
from a lot of civil war
which is like we i mean we can get an
expert
a lot of tribal a lot of um a lot of
it's just that's a different situation
whereas
i think the reason why the middle east
is so
there's so much going on there is
because it's
important you know and we see these
things in these important
countries like iran's important it's
like one of the biggest
uh suppliers of petroleum i think like
all these countries are very important
we don't really talk about
uruguay no offense to uruguay
or you [ __ ] i'm just saying there are
speakers
you're [ __ ]
so there are countries russia is really
important like west
the west actually not that they have so
much oil
america has more because of fracking
america has because of
fracking yes but i'm just saying where
there are reasons there are certain
countries that are just
important yeah yeah i agree i guess it's
just
and they're politicians i wonder what
it's just a form of government i wonder
what yes i wonder
it's just independent america and the
west
is it's like post enlightenment
and just using being rational and being
logical and but enlightenment happened
three years ago no but honestly like
it but historically it did because
it happened in the west but all of that
most of africa and most the middle east
all of the separation and the civil wars
are tribal or religious or
or religiously tribal you know what i
mean like it's it's
they're all it's all like no a lot of
them are political like the iran iraq
war wasn't
tribal but i think it was based on
muslim interpretation i think it was
based on sunni versia
and probably it was based on america
backing rock but i don't think we backed
them
we didn't just go hey we're backing you
if you want to find anybody no it's
because the shaw
was got taken down or we put the shot in
yeah you put the shot
right but let's just take iran for
example it has a
long history of being very pro-islam and
being very anti-islam before
when the shah was there you couldn't
veil in public yeah you were not allowed
to
and it really um it represented
radicals or it made them like they're
this is wrong also
right it's just the same thing here
where it's like oh we're feeling
oppressed and then this group gets
together and like
you know mobilizes and says so in iran
but just as an example for example
sometimes there's periods of history
where you can't
veil and you can't really practice islam
it's not a very islam friendly place
and then there's times where it is a
very islam friendly place but
just in iran for example it's
so heavy-handed with how
with how um uh much they force
islam that it's no one is happy they're
either about that you know so it's not
like
yeah finally islam yeah but i but then
you'll read polls or you'll see
like then they vote for the it's corrupt
yes but okay i that's as a westerner
yeah it's impossible to know who there
are three contradictory letters
yours your point of view is the fourth
one that everyone's got a different
point of view of course of course and
everyone's got a different
i'm also speaking specifically about
iran yes which doesn't is very different
than
a lot of the countries that are like
like lebanon
like syria it's it's different in
different countries
yeah like there's a again there's a
woman
there's a lot of contradictions in terms
of the
that this woman was a model apparently
oh yeah she stopped yeah she said i'm
gonna stop modeling because it's too
sexist
yeah and a bunch of uh
naomi campbell a bunch of people uh like
supported her
but at the same time if she said that
there we go in the name of christianity
it would have been at wrong it would
have she's mike pence
well she also if you go if you read what
she says
she was um she is mike pence no there's
definitely like a sku for sure that's
what i'm saying like so
when it's mike pence we all agree
that it's crazy to to
think of women and men like that and but
if it's islam we're all like you know
what it's a beautiful religion
but i don't think you're giving there's
plenty of things i mean when we talked
about t.i
you were sitting here like how is he
supposed to check her virginity that is
such a christian idea
and we're not and no not everybody was
against it right you know
like yeah it sounded hi uh it sounded
creepy but
yeah a lot of people do abide by that
[ __ ] and a lot of
places in outside of la in the bay
that wouldn't be weird but by the way
the same people that were condemning t.i
are for this woman do you know what i
mean like this
because that because it sounded creepy
but like you said but they were
they weren't i got a lot of flack on
twitter about it which is people going
like
you said it weird i just said it like i
i
truly don't know but what should a
father what should a father's approach
to his his
daughter's sexuality and and uh
sexual health be like i truly was like
i i've never had a kid what should it be
but
the point you made that i think no one
would disagree with which was the meat
and potatoes we were saying was that the
longer the later
you wait to have sex obviously not
forever but yeah the later you wait in
your like
15 you're good yeah like don't be a
loser
uh the later you're waiting in your
adolescent hood to have sex
the better it is for you that no one's
arguing with that and i think that was a
point
that's all the point i'm just saying
there's a lot of mainstream
christian ideals and whatever behavior
that people
sign up for that don't that aren't gonna
right but
liberals are would all be mike this
woman is making
a mother decision
it's basically the same the version of
like she might as well
mike pence's daughter but it's when it's
in the name of christianity liberals get
like
that's so backward and so and then when
it's islam
it's a complex it's an entirely
different story and that's what i
that's part of my point the other point
is like what is islam
and what are its long-term intentions
worldwide but that what you're saying
right now what is
it it i think the reason why liberals do
that
is because and the it's the same exact
reason why republicans
have a negative idea of islam is
it's the same thing it's that they don't
know it it's very hard to
hate on something that you don't know
it's not hard sorry but for a liberal
it's like well we don't
fully get it it's also the anatomy of my
enemies my friend so
they because they know right wing people
hate muslims especially after 9 11
they're like hey they're good people and
they don't i don't
know because there are plenty of people
because there's plenty there's plenty of
people that aren't would never identify
as a conservative or republican
that we're looking at sikhs like i don't
know about him
you know what i mean like there were i
feel like anti-muslim
but i can tell you firsthand that
that i can tell you that firsthand is
yeah but is
liberty the only reason liberals are for
islam is because they because
republicans are against it
i i okay so i disagree with you because
i think it almost mimics the rule
in comedy where uh if you want to make a
joke about something
you gotta be somehow associated to it
but if you
start making jokes about breast cancer
for survivors
no one's gonna laugh because it's just
it feels mean
and i feel like liberals don't know
enough about
islam to
find ways to to hate on it do you know
what i mean
i don't well i don't i think the same
thing would look
bad it looks bad you don't even know
enough
but they it looks bad to [ __ ] on muslims
after 9 11. i'm telling you i believe
i told him this one time and he's like i
think about all the time i go before 9
11
no one knew [ __ ] about islam yeah no one
was hating because
it was like nothing it was just it was
like towel head
yeah it was like yeah i think which is a
great one um
and uh duh yeah not in a sikh so
i would argue it's you ever see the bill
maher where ben affleck was defending
islam
and uh mar and maybe sam harris or
somebody were
citing this poll in i think it was saudi
arabia
where it's like 73 of muslims are
for sharia they're for muslim laws
as a governing in saudi arabia yes
again i'm miss but ben affleck's
defending defending defending and it's
purely a liberal defending
islam because he doesn't want to seem
racist against
muslims now if mike if you said mike
pence wants all this [ __ ]
it would have been a hook line and
sinker
against all the same [ __ ] and it's just
a matter of
what's the difference the difference is
liberals don't like uh the christians
and liberals are in a fight for control
the country in some ways
and uh it's the enemy of my enemies my
friend they
christians were against muslims so then
liberals are like well then we're for
them
uh it's like it's the same with with uh
immigration where liberals are like i'm
for i think
we should allow as any immigrants that
want how many
just ask any liberal what's the right
number
of should it be 300 million a year what
i i don't
this is where you lose me because i'm
like first of all our immigration policy
was very similar to that uh not that
long ago
and that's something but it wasn't
somewhat of that it was around
a million a year was a was like there's
something of a cap
and it ended up being but then but but
liberals are like we're sending all the
border and all that stuff and it's like
what's the right number but that's but
you're really boiling it down
to a way that makes liberals look
one like there's just one person
speaking the same thing i mean like come
on i agree but there is their liberal
tenants i mean there's like
for sure but i don't think under
both republican and democratic
administrations there's been like a
robust
immigration system that doesn't this is
the only one that's
really put the brakes on things just
based on
weird ethnocentric and like anti-muslim
laws so but it's also
anti-immigrant it's not he's not it's
only yeah he wants white people he wants
more white people but there's
but what i'm saying is this is the
this is weird what trump is doing is is
a little bit different but
most of the immigration laws hasn't
haven't changed that much and the
immigration you know system and the how
much they led in
it doesn't change that much between i
agree
democrat and republican but i don't but
most
liberals who say that they're for
immigration right
with robust and all acceptance don't
have any idea what the what it is
they don't know the number they don't
know when they don't know how they no
what the [ __ ] right people don't know
before something if you don't truly
know it that's my that's my room with
liberals it's like they don't know about
muslim but they know
it's a religion of peace and good
because they didn't want to seem
when when muslim guys were getting beat
up on the street
on 9 15 they were like this is wrong
and it was all uh seemingly right-wing
people doing it
they've defended them and without and it
was wrong
they were getting battered but
they don't know what they're defending
but it's everyone has their like
thing right but what i'm saying is
there's a ton of contradiction like this
woman said
with the model they're for it if but if
mike if christians do it it's
but there's hypo there's hypocrisy on
both sides and we're never gonna get i'm
just saying that like for example
for example it seems more like of course
liberals want to
uphold whoever's being like picked on
whoever's being you know unfairly
targeted and that for me is uh for me it
really is
trying to and i'm not saying liberals
are [ __ ]
holier than that but i'm saying it is
kind of true saying that they are saying
that and they actually act like that
so what i'm about to say sounds like i'm
doing the kool-aid but i'm not but it it
does feel like
it's kind of upholding the constitution
more it's like no let these people have
equality [ __ ] off
you don't have to agree with someone to
know there's plenty of lawyers that
represent
clan members and they're jewish lawyers
but liberals are not
they're not saying hey these christians
just want equality let them
let them do whatever they want right but
they're not going and prohibiting those
christians for
being not thanks to amy coney barrett
well we solved it we solved racism
and uh ethnocentrism and moving
moving on songs have no centricity
goodbye you've got mayo let's do this oh
one other one
another person said watch documentary
called our man in tehran which i believe
you're not going to believe this is a
front line oh yeah a man in tehran
tehran um uh you've got mail [ __ ]
oh all right neil
you [ __ ] with glasses on or off i had
a sex stream about
you not that long ago by the way your
body looked like [ __ ] in it
and then she puts her emails she's
trying to get them she's trying to get
that pick
um and you did have them on uh
being a part-time wearer of them they
can sometimes get in the way just
curious also
my friends and i were recently going
over our most embarrassing sex stories
and was wondering if you guys had any
good ones to share bianca you were
obviously beautiful on the outside
uh but also seemed to be as equally
beautiful on the inside thanks for being
a voice for the ladies neil love you and
your work no reference to my
insides your instincts suck yeah
i think that you gotta
i think that uh you gotta be careful
i try to take them off as late as
possible if i'm honest
can i see your face without them for a
second i miss
oh that seems positive
you seem the same yeah but i'm cuter
with glasses
a little cuter 10 10 to 15 i would say i
don't know
so what i'm saying is
this is the package this is the
agreement this is the agreement we have
a contract for the new list
my head shot is for the new classes
right yes
mark twain and three mikes and
committees of the world where i dropped
that
wonderful muslim joke that i do not
stand behind at all
that's the agreement so i i try to take
them off as late as possible
do you make sure the lights are all dim
i try to make sure no i just
not even it's not even conscious like
don't show her your face
uh where i don't know
i it just seems like that's the i'm
already getting ready to surprise her
with what what my dick looked like why
show her dick why
double why double double whammy here
uh with um it's the ultimate double
whammy it's my face and my dick
so much surprise look out so much
surprise that's
my dick in my face
it's the spiderman what if you actually
get spiderman
face or dick um spider-man pointing at
himself
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] that's such a good
thing god damn it what a great name
um so i think later
is better do you i you don't have
anything like that
clothes you try to keep your clothes on
for as long as possible because you
don't want to
give him that no okay great whatever
no when it makes sense i'm not like earn
this
titty embarrassing sex
story go um
went down on a woman woman i lost my
virginity to
and she said you've never done that
before have you wow
three weeks ago i'm sorry to say
uh yeah but it's just a great just a
great one
just a great like because i had i don't
even remember what i was doing
but i feel like it was labial
how about that too much too much sleep
really labia labeling
you know if you go a wrong way it's like
it's like petting a dog the wrong way
it's like
don't it's also don't like this
great great analogy but i it was like
the
i'm not gonna i don't i don't remember
anything but in my head it was like
i was like gnawing on the lower right
part of her lady like
down into the like like two inches
yeah like but there's nothing wrong i
don't know what i was doing
i don't know what exactly i was doing
but i also did not know what i was doing
so i don't remember what i was doing and
i don't really know what i was doing i
just went like
no no i'm blowing glad you leave
um uh so that's just a good slam
oh here's the second one that another
woman said to me in the same period
i was uh let's say i was digitally
manipulating her
what fingering oh again you brought it
on yourself
i tried to believe it i swear i thought
it was a photoshop
he basically said neil please say
fingered um wait fun fact
years to today years old i
i thought when they said digital
penetration i literally thought it was
like
a cell phone or some [ __ ] for a long
time why
i don't know how that's possible i don't
no you thought that they were taking
or like numbers
no digits taking physical no it's not
that bad
like digital technology sign at a at a
at a
shop they were taking them and shoving
them up women's positions
that's actually you know this is
supposed to be a safe place that's uh
digital is a
digital is a digital is a bad word for
fingers
yeah digi it's just like on it's too far
it's too far afield like yeah
keep it closer to fingers somehow like
you're not
there we go something yeah um
i don't love extremities that's another
one extremities for like hands and feet
are your extremities and it's like
it's two feet it's it's like two feet
away from the center of my body
at furthest it's two feet
okay digital fingering a woman
and she said it's not a change purse
uh just another great slang how many
fingers do you have in her
uh a bunch and a lot of change and like
a lot of nickels and quarters
no i was it's just a funny analogy hard
she's funny she yes is she still funny
she's she's always she was witty she's
not like professional comedians she's
she works in comedy she's funny yeah she
works in comedy she's yeah you still
homies
yeah but yeah but she's like married and
kids and [ __ ] okay
um yeah i'm like mine uh
i can't embarrassing i don't know one
time i was
i was really drunk and i
was on top this is i don't know how
embarrassing this is kind of
embarrassing i was on
top mom don't listen and
uh i just lost my balance and like
my head fell into his head and then i
had a black eye this was
during when you were shooting american
pie too
you got a black eye from [ __ ] that's
pretty embarrassing
it was bad i know so i just lied
about it i was like what just did you
guys finish
yeah i played it off great i was like oh
swelling
slowly swelling up i'm fine
no i'm fine uh yeah that was not good
i didn't like that you headbutted them
on the other side to make it
make it seem like it was intentional and
it was one of those uh black eyes that
it's not like the whole thing it was
just the one where it looks like do you
have dirt
or yeah so a lot of people brought it up
yeah it was like
uh that's moving on wild story
i mean it's like that's a perfectly
embarrassing that's like
physical comedy done i one time
similarly
was playing golf and gave myself a black
eye
now almost impossible to do no
yes so there were i was uh
hitting ball like whatever in my
parents backyard um which
again makes me sound like i'm from money
which i
again does i guess technically chris
rock is no you are rich yeah
i don't know you're a rich kid that's
what chris that's chris take away from
three mike
um railroad tie
thick piece of wood ball against it i
hit
uh chip shot just wondering what would
happen and what happened was
it flew right at my eye and
bouche it swelled i could see the
swelling by the time the ball
hit the ground again it was like boom
black eye
over you got a black eye swelling you
can see it from your eye
and your cheek and i got bones sharp
cheekbone this is before they
they came in oh and so did anybody say
anything
a teacher at my school openly made fun
of me
i mean
um yeah it was funny it's like what are
the [ __ ] odds
it's like [ __ ] it's they made fun of
me as much as they would have made fun
of you if you told them well
no i would never i would um girl i'm
sure guys would have been like you know
bianca i'm saying i would never
give you a blackout you would never lose
your balance with me no
goodbye you've got mail uh hey pringles
and ankles lcnar i've heard neil say in
the past
this guy's got issues uh i've i've heard
neil say in the past comedy is a natural
talent i simply don't believe this is
the case
i say so because i've had meager comedic
coming uh to comedy success online
but after taking two two plus
of intensive improv classes i feel as
i've
if i've become significantly funnier it
also rubs me the wrong way when neil
talks about how he'll talk with seth
meyers about sketch
on a level other people wouldn't
understand of course you both
have contributed to sketch comedy in
historical ways
but to act like other people he simply
wouldn't get it
seems pretentious and dumb i think neil
believes he's a stock broker
in the marketplace of ideas
uh my question is do you really not
believe comedy can be learned skill and
you have to be born with it
how feel but dinky what's a neil
thinking
dude you struck a chord this guy
now this is his more significantly funny
version of this letter
so uh guy i'm sorry to tell you
i know more about comedy than
most people the same way you would have
no problem saying
blake knows more about basketball than
most people
because he plays basketball
professionally for
some reason when it comes to comedy
everybody thinks they can do it and that
their opinion and i'm here to tell you
guy
it isn't true and i will restate it
it's you gotta be born with it uh
chris rock has told me things he said in
grade school
that most comedians would
be ha would do on television now
uh i remembered something i said
in seventh grade that i was like not
only was that
[ __ ] really funny it was my entire
sense of humor
laid out yeah the the exact joke i'd
make now and i made it
in 1987. i think one time
here comes oh keith didn't bark
he didn't greet me he didn't bark he's
on his own [ __ ] right now okay
yeah he's planning he's planning a
surprise party
he's been super quiet
it's too long um so
wait that really distracted me i wanted
to tell you something oh one time i
me and a friend we hung out with dave it
was a whole entire day
and i remember thinking
i think i told him and her i was like
you know
we could have made someone could have
made
20 sketches or
one or two tv show ideas based on the
random [ __ ] he just said yeah
like just random yes
yeah never would even remember even if i
told him
like the joke it's just so that's when
someone's brain just keeps
going they've absorbed they've you
guys's brains really
just morph into this yeah it's this
weird thing where people
are resentful about it's like dog there
are people that are funnier than me
i enjoy it i don't [ __ ] i'm not mad
at chris
i'm not mad at dave i'm not mad at bill
i'm not mad at any of these guys
for being a little funnier than me i'm
like [ __ ]
and i don't think a class is going to
get me there but also
you guys kind of not like
being a good comedian doesn't mean
you're killing it in other
places in your life like you guys brains
think in bits you find
yes it's just a weird extra
little thing but you know what's funny
you can develop it
don't get me wrong but something's gotta
be there this guy's
mad that i'm going like no there is a
thing about comedy
that i understand yeah more than that
you
don't there's things about comedy that
other comedians don't understand that i
understand
and i'm not they're not that mad at me
about it and i'm not mad at
chris and the guys that i think are
funnier than me i'm not like
[ __ ] louis ck right [ __ ] guy
it's just like no i don't [ __ ] enjoy
the show
you know what i noticed though is that
for example when people say they're an
actor for example
when people say they're an actor and
actress uh
everyone's aspiring did you what have
you been in that i've seen
like [ __ ] you you know how hard it is to
be in something you [ __ ]
um whereas the
moment people say oh i'm a comedian
instant respect oh he's a comedian oh
yeah she's a comedian
and they'll be like open mikers or maybe
they're at it for like a year or two
look at a mic tattoo they get so much
more respect
at least in this town i'm not talking
about throughout the world um
and i always thought like dude become
saying you're a comedian
and i go up at the store my friend my
friend goes over this door blah blah
blah blah blah like no dude
you're not i mean you are a comedian
fine but i think
because you can be a comedian so quickly
everyone feels like they are sitting at
the
illuminati comedian throne table well
yeah
of course there's that but it's also
this guy's like
you and seth don't know more about
sketches than
than i do you both historically
contributed to sketch comedy
but yet i still tell myself that you're
not
better than me it's like dawg i don't
what do you want i don't know how to
disabuse you of this but basketball
there are certain things where people
ever the problem with comedy is everyone
thinks they're a little funny
and everyone is a little funny everyone
else says funny songs this is different
than kind of it's just a
different like i'm talking about a
different professional structured
from nothing wake up think of it like
your brain just structures a sketch
quickly
it's not you can i've gotten better at
it clearly
but the level of resentment that somehow
i'm a
cultural gatekeeper no the audience is
the gate
the gatekeeper and i just see what
people can do for an audience to go
oh this guy's [ __ ] good or i can
speak to them
privately and hear them say things
that are so you wouldn't even know
what to you wouldn't even know what i'm
talking about right
like again yeah he wouldn't he wouldn't
know what i'm talking about
but he's mad at it but basketball
there's certain things he politics
basketball there's certain [ __ ] people
have no problem admitting although less
and less now in america
everyone's yeah everyone's like
everyone's equal but this
guy for some reason just doesn't want to
believe that that i could be funnier
than him in a way that no class
can teach me but meanwhile he would have
no problem going oh [ __ ] billboard's
so much funny than you knew
him would have no problem his
appraisal's as legitimate as mine
well the problem is that the access to
entry and calling yourself a comedian is
so
everybody like even people will be like
you should do com
yuck no offense but now i would never
want to and it's also because
it's a job i i don't i don't think going
up
and going on a mic i think everybody
could probably say something funny one
time on a mic
if they really tried not everybody but i
don't think that's the issue it's like
you gotta want this thing you gotta go
up you have to work on it you have to do
all this stuff
and i think people don't realize that so
the respect they give comedy it feels
more accessible than it actually truly
is to be a good comic
because because we make it look easy
make it look easy
and it's like you guys are kind of
hanging it's like oh you just go on a
stage
and a lot of it comes from you it's not
like you have to take an acting class
you don't have to ignite this but
maybe it helps or maybe it's really just
like you could be very funny at home
alone in des moines
could be a really funny person yeah and
there's it's yeah
so that's the problem it's like oh
comedy so now i'm a comedian it's like
no it's being funny and comedy being
comedian i mean seinfeld did the jerry
before seinfeld special and he says
in the special he goes like
you all think you're a little funny
everyone who comes to a comedy show
thinks that
right you're the funny one in your group
so then you come and go like let me
[ __ ] see what this guy's got and
he's got jerry seinfeld's creative
output
but there's certain [ __ ] they would be
this guy's also probably more respectful
of guys that have only been performers
than he would be of
me no because i've been a writer on him
no i that's a true thing that you
you're gonna you'll until you see it
you don't you there's no distinction
between you and
i mean here's my point i promise you
guys more respect for
ra rock if chris said the same thing
he'd be like all right
okay so you mean like it with your
opinion he's gonna take
chris is a lot more than yours yeah
because he's more successful and
better but he listens to the podcast and
you're very funny
so right but yeah that's fine but he
doesn't
he ma he's mad that i'm telling him
i'm he also thinks i'm saying you're not
funny what i'm saying is
no class is gonna teach you
[ __ ] is not your our brains are
composed differently
they just are they've been composed
differently from
little from small times they are they've
just been composed differently from
little so
also you've been working in comedy and
writing and sketch comedy for so long
right
all that all that
neil's [ __ ] old give him some respect
to the bung
super dude yeah so but again
it's it's the thing that they don't want
to give me respect i i we gotta go
yeah we'll do the rest of these next
week okay thanks for listening
[Music]
goodbye
oh yeah yeah yeah well stop the song
well we ended the show because we don't
have to take this [ __ ] anymore
bye goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
so